ja wir kommen zur heutigen sitzung
wir wollen heute nochmal uns mit
aristoteles befassen
hören sie mich können sie mich verstehen
genau wie in der letzten sitzung kam mir
nicht mehr ganz zu ende wir konnten
nicht alle zitate von aristoteles
diskutieren weil aristoteles ein sehr
schwieriger denker ist ich habe deswegen
auch ganz bewusst an die erste stelle
nicht chronologisch wie es eigentlich
gehörte ihn gestellt sondern mit
augustinus angefangen weil augustinus
unserem heutigen denken lebensweltlich
jedenfalls näher steht und auch ein
bisschen verständlicher die ganze sache
formuliert aber heute kommen wir nicht
drum herum heute müssen wir ihn
behandeln ich habe auch schon in der
zusammenfassung der letzten sitzung ein
bisschen seine theorie behandelt haben
sie die zusammenfassung bekommen oder
gibt es jemand unter ihnen der sich noch
nicht bekommen hat sind sie alle
eingetragen in meiner liste
sonst finden sie auch alles auf der app
für lukas tab die ich jetzt was jetzt
zum letzten mal sie können beruhigt sein
rw ok und in der zweiten hälfte der
heutigen sitzung wurde vielleicht im
letzten drittel je nachdem wie wir
vorankommen werden wir uns dann mit
isaac newton fassen also wieder ein
riesen zeitsprung unternehmen diesmal
nicht zurück wie im falle von augustinus
zu aristoteles sondern praktisch in der
zeit zum jüngeren oder aktuelleren hin
und isaac newton wollen wir seine
konzeption der absoluten zeit behandeln
vor dem hintergrund nicht zuletzt der
relativitätstheorie die wände
übernächsten sitzung kurzen kennenlernen
wollen und selbst auch mal versuchen uns
für
aber in der nächsten sitzung jedenfalls
wird dann um die debatte gehen zwischen
am leibnitz und minuten also 1 leibnitz
möchte ich gerne auch noch entgegen
jetzt dem ursprünglichen semester plan
auch noch mit aufnehmen und das war dann
nächsten übernächsten sitzung erfolgen
bevor wir dann auch noch ich verspreche
ihm auf die ganz berühmte
relativitätstheorie die allgemeine
eingehen
da werde ich mir noch ein bisschen was
überlegen wie wir das gemeinsam
verstehen können wir hier zeit behandelt
wird also heute noch mal hier um den
diesen herren hier und zwar um seine
physik geht das ist also eine schrift
und da geht es um das vierte buch und um
vier sehr kompakte kapitel die aber sehr
sehr differenziert verfasst sind und die
nicht ganz leicht zu verstehen sind
hallo und wie immer wir jetzt den text
uns gemeinsam etwas durchlesen möchte
ich ein paar leitfragen wieder an die
wand werfen und zwar laut und die wie
verhalten sich zahlen und zeit nach
aristoteles zueinander eine andere frage
ist wie verhalten sich zeit und bewegung
zueinander das ist jetzt also bei
aristoteles ganz wichtig die frage wie
können wir zeit messen wie können wir
zeit wahrnehmen also zeit wird irgendwie
gezählt hat eine taktung und eine
weitere frage ist die und theologische
frage also man könnte sagen wie
verhalten sich zeigen bewegung zusammen
oder zahl und zeit ist eine logische
oder vielleicht sogar auch noch eine
psychologische frage wie können wir zeit
kennen messen bis hämisch uns derzeit
annähernd dazu brauchen wir
veränderungen bewegung taktung ein maß
und diese frage die jetzt gekommen ist
ist eine ontologische frage wie
existiert seit existiert sie überhaupt
oder ist sie nur eine illusion
diese frage ist natürlich auch schon bei
augustinus vorgekommen diese frage wird
immer wieder auftauchen auch bei denen
ganz relativ jungen texten wie von
mctaggart den habe ich ihnen
genannt ich schreibe noch mal hin
[Applaus]
mctaggart und der hat diese berühmte
theorie die ich jetzt schon ein paar mal
erwähnt habe aber auf die wir eben
chronologischen zu sprechen kommen
werden der a 3 und der b 3 der zeit
entwickelte reihe ist eine reihe in der
zeit wo sie sich das so vorstellen
müssen wie bei augustinus der
vertretende arbeit der zeit also dass
wir immer ein iks haben ein kreuz oder
einen punkt in der zeitreihe für die für
das als ein subjekt letztendlich für das
etwas zukünftig ist und etwas vergangen
ist
also wird es gibt ein zeitverständnis
wonach zukünftig kite und vergangenheit
thematisch werden weil das ixs was da in
dieser zeit leistete sich befindet weil
das so was sagen kann wie gestern wie
heute wie morgen also es kann in
mexikanische zug nahmen herstelle sind
man in mexikanischen dieses da heute
morgen das ist natürlich immer relativ
wenn ich jetzt einen satz formulieren
morgen regnet ist dann ist dieser satz
was sein war heizwert anbelangt dieser
satz kann wahr oder falsch seien
dann ist dieser satz was ein war
heizwert angelangt anbelangt
problematisch warum ist dieser satz
problematisch was sein war heizwert
anbelangt was die frage betrifft ob es
richtig ist ob es regnet oder nicht
dennoch die frage ist ja welche
meinst du jetzt dieser tag diese aussage
ist relativ auf den zeitpunkt meiner
äußerung dieses satzes
je nachdem wann nicht diesen satz
ausspreche davon hängt ab ob er wahr
oder falsch ist mal eben jedes morgen
wie sie die sagen reden bringen kann
oder regen nicht bringen kann und damit
möchte ich ihnen jetzt nur demonstrieren
was ist eine relativität oder index
qualität so eine abhängigkeit vom
zeitpunkt auch für den wahrheitsgehalt
und in dieser abhängigkeit müssen sie
sich eben auch diese arbeit vorstellen
das ist also diese zeit wo es eben immer
eine zukunft gibt die noch nicht
eingetreten ist eine vergangenheit und
fünf jahre später ist natürlich die
zukunft wenn wir sagen
drei jahre ist die zukunft ist natürlich
schon eingetreten und gehört zur
vergangenheit
das heißt wenn wir hier von zukünftig
sprechen ist das immer relativ auf die
zeit so wie wir morgen wenn wir morgen
sagen ist das heute vom heutigen tag dem
6 november ist das natürlich 600 wenn
man alles ist natürlich der siebte
morgen wenn ich aber morgen morgen sage
ist es eben nicht mehr der siebte alles
hängt davon ab wann ich diese diese
bezugnahmen hersteller also zukünftig
keiten vergangenheit sind nach dieser
abhängig von dem subjekt und seine
regierung in dieser zeit strahl und es
gibt eben eine beere für die spielt
diese vergangenheiten diese zukunft die
an zukunft bewusst sein dass an ein
subjekt gebunden ist keine rolle und
diese zeit auffassung der b3 die
interessiert einfach nur was war früher
was war später und die aussage etwas war
früher die ist nicht so verfasst wie die
aussage morgen wird es regnen
wenn ich sage aber früher als b also
mehr ein gegensatz dazu haben wir hier
ist jetzt noch einmal c und hier ist die
zeit verläuft so dann ist die aussage
war früher oder c ist älter wie auch
immer als die diese aussage kann ich
objektiv behaupten und sie ist wahr oder
falsch aber in diesem fall ist jetzt war
beim cjd war unabhängig von dem
zeitpunkt wann ich die aussage tätigen
ist einfach eine absolute relation c
kommt etwas vor
und das ist unabhängig von einem subjekt
was ich in der zeitleiste findet und und
solche aussagen wie jetzt zwar früher
als der oder die war später dort ist
jünger als sie von solchen zeit aussagen
macht jetzt natürlich die physik
gebraucht und das ist so eine könnte
jetzt sagen so eine abstrakte konzeption
von zeit die nicht das objekt der zeit
erfahrung mit einbezieht
das ist ein bisschen abstraktion man hat
ja gar kein subjekt mehr was
vergangenheit zum zukunftserwartungen
oder bewusstsein dafür kann man
objektiver von dieser zeit sprechen also
das wollte ich ihn noch mal vor greifen
und sagen dass wir immer auch jetzt von
mctaggart diese a und die b 3 vor augen
haben sie mir immer fragen redet jetzt
der von einer arie oder von einer beere
augustinus offensichtlich redet von
einer arena für ihn spielt immer die
vergangenheit und die zukunft eine rolle
das subjekt er wird dort sehr wichtig
ich wiederhole noch mal kurz was ich in
den letzten und vorletzten sitzung auch
es ist so dass wir uns gedanken machen
müssen darüber wie wir das objekt
derzeit erfahrung mit der zeit dem
zeitstrahl in der verbindung setzen es
gibt zwei möglichkeiten also ich habe es
schon ein paar mal gesagt es kann sein
wir ruhen gewissermaßen wir sind fixiert
und die zeit kommt auf uns zu
also die zeit läuft durch uns durch von
der zukunft zugegen war da trifft es
durch und durch
und dann geht sie in die vergangenheit
über und wir ruhen letztendlich und sie
strömt auf uns zu und sie gegen die
vergangenheit und das legt auch das wort
zukunft nahe zukunft ist das was auf uns
zukommt und dass ein zeitverständnis ein
anderes zeitverständnis ist das dass man
in der zeit nach vorne fährt also dass
man dass die zeit fließt und wir mit der
zeit mit schwimmen im strom der zeit
nach vorne uns bewegen hat hatte sind
wir nicht mehr das ruhen des objekts
sind da nimmt die zeit uns mit
gewissermaßen und diese diese zwei
auffassung der zeit sollten wir auch
immer berücksichtigen also wie sich das
objekt derzeit erfahrung zurzeit
allgemein verhält das einfach nur mal so
als eine generelle betrachtungsweise
derzeit ok und dann kann man sich doch
fragen wie sich natürlich die zeit
theorien von augustinus und aristoteles
zueinander verhalten
das ist auch eine ganz spannende frage
also wir haben werden jetzt gleich sehen
haben sie auch eine letzten sitzung
schon gesehen dass es da durchaus einige
gemeinsamkeiten gibt aber vielleicht hat
aristoteles noch ein bisschen mehr
baureihe oder interessen in seiner
theorie die die bereiche betreffen und
nicht so sehr die a3 wir wollen uns
allen einfach diese frage stellen und
jetzt lese ich noch mal kurz also
vor das hat mir aber in der letzten
sitzung auch schon gehabt sagt zunächst
ist es von vorteil hier über über die
zeit perry como also connors ist die
zeit schreibt mir auf griechisch hin
so müsste man das schreiben also das ist
ein ca
chronos
da wie immer zurückkommen wollen sie da
sich die griechischen begriff immer in
der umschrift angeht also jetzt so oder
wollen sie da sich die im original auch
angeben wer ist für original einfach mal
hin wer ist vorschrift um schritt ist
ein bisschen mehr gut dann mache ich sie
mit umschrift also ich kann auch beides
machen ganz genau also das ist jetzt die
dass es mal gesehen haben können sie
auch ganz leicht lernen das ist das so
dass er das ist nikon ist genauso wie im
deutschen das ist ein bisschen spät das
ist kein faust und das ist also ein ende
und damit enorme komme dass ein sieg man
es am ende ganz ähnlich im deutschen
also connors die zeit und da sagt jetzt
aristoteles sei es von vorteil über
diese zeit zweifelsfragen anzustellen
auch mittels äußerlich herbeigezogen und
belegungen nämlich ob sie zum seinen es
ist
und wir dass es angehört oder zum nicht
sein denn zum mehr und mehr ist eben das
nicht
und dann war es ihr wirkliches wesen ist
es ist die physis ist das feature
siekmann utah genau der physis und
physis wird eigentlich übersetzt mit
natur hat er der kommilitone der heute
nicht da ist das letzte mal gesagt ja
aber müsste es nicht irgendwie ein
anderes griechisches wort sein für wesen
cia oder sowas bei platon findet man die
usa das ist die wiesn habe ich diesen
zeiten ein aristoteles sagt die physis
ist mein natur aber im weitesten sinne
des wortes sowie im deutschen wir sagen
würden es ist eben die natur der sache
dass die natur der sache und damit sage
ich ist es das wesen das sagt so ist die
sache erhalten
als es so dass es die frage was ist denn
ihr wesen und interessant ist auch dass
aristoteles wie sie hier am titel sehen
die zeit in der physik behandelt also
ziemlich modern wir würden ja auch heute
sagen generell wenn man fragt ja wo wird
die zeit überhaupt noch behandelt in
welcher disziplin würde man
wahrscheinlich sagen und der physik der
mathematik bestimmt nicht die zeit als
zeit die zeit als größe t
das ist eine größe das ist etwas was die
physik macht und dann kann man sich
natürlich fragen ja und wieso kommt der
cd philosophie ins spiel und die antwort
auf die frage warum die philosophie sich
denn überhaupt mit der zeit beschäftigen
soll ist unter anderem die dass man
sagen kann es gibt halt noch
vielleicht eine art es gibt vielleicht
noch ein subjekt was zeit erfahrung hat
oder macht und ich will damit nicht
sagen dass die philosophie auch über die
b3 einfach nur dass früher oder später
interessante aussagen machen könnte ich
glaube dass eben ganz besonders die
philosophie da ins spiel kommen wo man
eben nicht davon ausgeht dass die zeit
nur etwas ist was früher später sein
kann sondern dass die zeit problematisch
ist weil man immer zeit subjektiv
wahrnimmt und weil jedenfalls als mensch
die frage ist wie sieht es aus bei wesen
die keine zeit erfahrung haben natürlich
unterliegen die auch derzeit aber das
ist doch was ganz besonderes ist wenn so
was die gegenwart vergangenheit und
zukunft zu sprechen und ihren
theologischen status und jedenfalls er
fordert in seiner schrift über die
physik und er fragt jetzt nach dem wesen
und ob sie seiend ist oder nicht und die
problematik der frage ob sie existiert
ist eben was könnte das problem noch mal
sein wiederholen warum fragt jetzt
aristoteles ob die zeit ist ob sie zum
sein denn gehört oder nicht gehört was
ist der grund dafür warum kann auch das
total ist diese frage stellen man könnte
noch sagen natürlich ist die zeit das
war was sollte die frage warum ist es
berechtigt die frage aufzuwerfen ob sie
ist oder nicht ist was sie sagen denken
sie mal ein bisschen zurück an
augustinus
ja ja ja mache das was haben wenn sie es
bis 28
genau also wir können da waren ja wie
kann ich sie denn also ich muss hier
erkennen und ich musste ja verorten im
raum ist im raum komischen also die zeit
ist kein gegenstand
also das ist schon eine sehr
interessante sache die zeit ist nichts
wie jetzt hier mein smartphone was da so
liegt und was ich so betrachten kann
das ist eine möglichkeit einfach sagen
sie so was hat sich eine
gegenständlichkeit hat sie überhaupt
eine gegenständlichkeit wahrscheinlich
nicht sie hat ihr was würde sagen es hat
er eine form würde ich jetzt mal
vorschlagen dass sie ist nichts
gegenständliches an ihren form in der
wir überhaupt erfahrungen machen können
das ist schon mal ein punkt da ist eine
meldung wir messen nicht verstehen kann
keine fragen
die zeit des tages und werde als service
koste daran vielleicht etwas zu sagen
wenn die erde
alle existenten genau also man kann sich
also ein guter punkt mann und das geht
jetzt wird ja auch die auf die frage von
aristoteles zurück wie kann man
überhaupt zeit bestimmen wir können
jährige nur an veränderungen verstehen
immer nur relational und diese
relationen die sind irgendwie bisschen
willkürlich also wo gibt's denn die
kleinste einheit anhand deren ich maas
habe die zeit wirklich zu bestimmen so
wie ich es ja bei zahlen haben nur 1 und
2 3 also das ist eine spannende frage
mir ist noch ein weiterer punkt gekommen
und ganz banal den hatten wir bei
augustinus schon gehabt ja wie kann denn
die zeit überhaupt existieren wenn sie
doch diese bekannte problem als
zukünftige noch nicht ist als übergang
nicht mehr ist und als gegenwärtige im
verschwinden begriffen und eigentlich
aus den uns los ist in der gegenwart
weit wenn sie eine ausdehnung hätte in
der gegenwart
also wenn wir jetzt hier so ein
stückchen herausgreifen ist die
gegenwart
das kann man dann machen dass das
problem immer sagen die zeit ist dagegen
hat ausgedient
ich kann nicht dieses argument wieder
problematisieren ja genau und ich kann
jedenfalls sagen also jedenfalls schon
schon schritt weiter man könnte jetzt
sagen na gut wenn sie die ausbildung hat
dann hat sie zukünftigen anteil nämlich
den hier und den vergangenen anteil
und dann kommt diese verkleinerung ja
gut dann müsste ich muss ich dieses
mädchen hier wieder vergrößern
man hat doch wieder zukünftig anteil und
wieder an vergangene anteil also die
gegenwart kann eigentlich nicht sagt
jedenfalls augustinus ausgedient zahlen
weil aus den nebenstrecken in der zeit
gedrückt erstreckung gezeigt bedeutet
einen zukünftigen anteil zu haben und
ein vergangenen anteil zu haben und
zukünftig und vergangene anteile sind
immer noch nicht bzw
nicht mehr das ist so das problem also
man kann sich fragen existiert seit
überhaupt wenn dann nur in der gegenwart
und die gegenwart ist eben ein
wimpernschlag nicht mal dass sie hat
eigentlich keine ausdehnung ja
seit jahren extrem schnell innerhalb von
wenigen ergebnisse haben sie sich
stürzen
ja das ist jetzt das ist ein guter punkt
als sie bringen jetzt einen weiteren
aspekt ins spiel das ist also das
subjektive zeitempfinden was nochmal
unterschieden werden muss von der a3 a3
bedeutet jetzt nicht die relativität
derzeit in sofern sie für den ein- oder
in manchen situationen schneller oder
langsamer verfliest sondern in der aare
meint die zeit relativität nur dass eben
gegenwart und zukunft immer abhängig
sind von dem zeitpunkt und im subjekt
seiner situierung von dem aus eben etwas
gegen werder ist jetzt ihr punkt ist
jetzt die frage
verläuft die zeiten dass auch noch ein
wichtiger punkt so sie denn verläuft und
da merken wir wieder wenn wir sagen die
zeit verläuft dann reden wir über die
zeit wie ein gegenstand wir reden über
die zeit immer metaphorisch ist auch
noch ein ganz wichtiger punkt wir haben
die tendenz die zeit so zu behandeln als
sei sie nicht die zeit als sie ein strom
von wasser wir haben riesenprobleme über
die zeit sinnvoll verständlich zu reden
und wir wenn wir das haben dann bemerken
wir in ganz verschiedenen gegenstands
bereichen der philosophie dass wir dann
metaphorisch über diesen gegenstand
reden zu als wäre etwas anderes und das
ist eine interessante frage die sie
jetzt aufhören wenn die zeit verfliest
also der mann so redet muss bei dem
alarm leuchte erscheinen dann würden sie
sagen verfließen von zeiten jetzt im auf
einer metaphorischen eben wir reden
jetzt nicht mehr eigentlich wir reden
jetzt eigentlich über die zeit
dann müssen ja kann sich unterschiedlich
schnell verschließen oder hat sie das
auch noch wichtige punkt hat sie
dieselbe geschwindigkeit mit der sie
verschließt also da kann es ja wieder
fragen mit der sie auf uns so strömt und
dann flüchtet tempus fugit sie kennen
diesen spruch die zeit fliegt
die zeit fehlt jetzt kann man sich
fragen ja in welche richtung flieht sie
flieht vor uns fliegen wir in ihr fliegt
sie durch uns hindurch verriet sie uns
der und in den händen wie auch immer sie
jedenfalls will sagen sie flieht dann
unterstellen wieder zeigen dass sie eine
bewegung hat und zwar dass sie ganz
schnell verschließen
ich glaube das ist der punkt mit tempus
fugit ist gemeint dieser übergang von
gegen von zukunft so gegenwart
vergangenheit besonders der übergang von
der gegenwart in die vergangenheit
dass also die zeit wie man ja auch sagen
nicht die zeit vernichtet das ist glaube
ich das was in diesem moment ist dass
dieses spruchs tempus fugit die zeit
fliegt das ist glaube ich damit gemeint
hat die zeit fliegt flieht von sie ist
weg sie getrennt von uns weg ja und das
ist glaube ich dann die vorstellung dass
sie durch uns hindurch rennt und das ist
dann die flucht die flucht ist
letztendlich von der gegenwart in die
vergangenheit das ist glaube ich die
flugzeug lese ich jetzt diese
metaphorische redeweise von der zeit als
ob sie fliehen wird das sehen sie die
zeit wird nicht nur als ein gegenstand
metabolisiert dass man sagt sie fließt
oder youtube vergeht sondern sie wird
auch noch als ein subjekt gefasst das
ist andermatt noch mal vier
problematisch die zeit fliegt das hatte
ich eine hochproblematische
metaphorische rede weil sich auch noch
als subjekt als vielleicht akteur das
jetzt nicht direkt im alten subjekt war
es etwas tut gesehen wird das heißt wir
projizieren aktivitäten die uns
betreffen in der zeit in die zeit selbst
hinein und das ist das problem und jetzt
kann man sich wie sie richtig sagen
fragen ja wen sie denn fließt und wenn
wir so über sie reden können fließt sie
dann immer gleich schnell also im
gleichen takt das ist wird die frage
nach dem zählen oder fließt sie
unterschiedlich schnell
natürlich kann man sich jetzt fragen
wenn im traum alles schneller
ist sie dann nicht dennoch gleich
schnell geflossen so wir hatten eben sie
ist so empfunden und da muss man auch
noch darunter scheinen sie fließt wohl
auch im traum genauso schnell aber wir
uns kommt es eben schneller vor das ist
dann also nochmal eine höhere form von
subjektivität über die bloße
subjektivität diese arbeit die bloße
relationale tätigen hinweggeht und dann
die ganz spannende frage tatsächlich wo
diese frage nach dem schneller oder
langsamer
auch ökologisch und jetzt nicht nur mit
hervorgeht relevant wird ist die
relativitätstheorie wo dann wirklich die
zeit plötzlich in eine abhängigkeit ist
von anderen größen von raum und von
geschwindigkeit und da wird die rede von
dem schneller oder langsamer derzeit
wirklich aber da ist immer noch nicht
dass da so können wir wirklich objektiv
über das schneller oder langsamer
derzeit sprechen wenn wir eben sind
dieser relativitätstheorie darüber
sprechen das machen wir in zwei bis drei
sitzungen da kommen aber das ist ein
wichtiger aspekt den wir bislang noch
nicht thematisiert haben dieses
schneller oder langsamer als zehn mann
ist es ein riesenproblem über die zeit
überhaupt zu sprechen
und jetzt sagt aristoteles folgendes in
seiner oder sie haben sie noch gewählt
ich hab's nicht angenommen wollen sie es
noch sagen hatten sie noch einen
wichtigen punkt der noch drüber hinweg
also die frage warum zeit glaube ich
existiert und wie kann sie existieren
könnte oder nicht existieren
ok entschuldigung her ok alle zeigt
erwartet dass sie nun also entweder
überhaupt nicht wirklich ist oder nur
unter anstrengen und auf dunkle weise
das möchte man aus folgenden
tatbeständen vermuten dass ein teilstück
von iris zur übergegangen und ist
insoweit nicht mehr das andere steht
noch gefroren ist insoweit noch nicht
aus diesen stücken besteht sowohl die
ganze unendliche wie auch die jeweils
genommene zeit was nun aus licht zahlen
dem zusammengesetzt ist von dem scheint
es doch wohl unmöglich zu sein
das ist am sein teilhabe
also geht es noch ein stückchen weiter
wie augustinus obwohl er vorher sagt
also diese teilstück problematik also
offensichtlich besteht die zeit aus
lauter zeitpunkt auch noch eine große
frage die ich noch mein bewusstsein
rufen möchte weitere frage also kann sie
schneller langsamer fließen wenn sie
überhaupt da fließt ist noch die frage
besteht sie aus punkten aus letzten
nicht mehr weiter analysiert waren
einheiten sprich sie diskret oder
besteht aus ist sie kontinuierlich
verfasst also ist die so verfasst dass
wenn ich jetzt mit der lupe darin rein
gehe und ein zeitpunkt betrachte dass er
dann wieder größer ist und ich wieder
weitere teile finden und so bis uns
endlich also wie eigentlich bei einem
zahlen kontinuum wo ich auch keine
letzten zahl einheiten habe sondern ich
kann einen zahlen bereich immer weiter
dividieren bis ins unendliche
aber da komme ich nie auf so einem fixen
eine fixe größe die nicht weiter
definierbar ist ich kann bei jeder größe
da kann ich wieder sagen geteilt durch
zwei das kann nicht unendlich markt und
dann bekomme ich halt so was dass es
halt gegen null geht
sympathisch und bekommen die
sympathische verhältnisse mit so ein
liebes lebens niemals verhältnis aber es
läuft wirklich nur im unendlich auf
einen bestimmten punkt zu und jetzt sagt
aristoteles hier wenn ich mir jetzt
einen zeitpunkt herausgreifen und davon
ausgeht dass die zeit
das gerät ist also zusammengesetzt ist
aus lauter zeitpunkten dann habe ich das
problem dass ein zeitpunkt daneben als
ausgedehnt auch wenn nur eine ganz ganz
kleinen dimension betrachtet werden muss
und dass ich dann das problem dass der
zeitpunkt wie wir hier schon bei also da
später nach augustinus gesehen hatte
eigentlich immer wieder zerfällt in noch
nicht und nicht mehr und wenn das bei
einem einzelnen zeitpunkt der fall ist
dann ist es natürlich bei allen
zeitpunkten so wenn sie identisch sind
und das heißt natürlich dass wenn wir
uns die ganze zeit so durch zeitpunkt
vorstellen die ebenso beschaffen sind
wie dieser hier
dass die zeit gar nicht ist mir alle
zeit punkte wenn sie ausgedient wären
eben in anteile des noch nicht und nicht
mehr verlegt werden könnten und damit
wäre dann ganz logisch natürlich wie so
eine einsetzung das ganze das ganze habe
ich sagen konnten ob das ganze diskrete
die ganze diskrete reihe von zeitpunkten
nicht bayern einzelner punkt auch nicht
ist so verstehe ich jetzt dieses
argument ich weiß nicht wie sie sehen
sehen sie es ähnlich oder haben sie noch
einen anderen anderem gedanken zu diesem
zitat also das ist jedenfalls so könnte
man sich vorstellen dass möchte man
vermuten sagte das so ist es natürlich
nicht
natürlich existiert sie drehen aber man
könnte jetzt mal vater denkt ja gut nur
in einem zeitpunkt nicht existiert und
die zeit aus lauter punkten besteht dann
existiert sie eben nicht alles ein
bisschen bis ein bisschen paradox aber
so argumentiert eben aristoteles
außerdem von jedem teilbaren dinge
falsch es ist müssen solange es ist
entweder alle seine teiles sein oder
doch einige von derzeit dagegen sind die
anteile schon vor über die anderen
stehen noch bevor
es ist keiner und das wo sie doch
teilbar ist das jetzt aber ist nicht
teil der time ist das ganze aus und das
ganze muss aus den teilen bestehen die
zeit aber besteht ganz offensichtlich
nicht aus den jetzt aber ein sehr
interessantes zitat mir scheint dass
aristoteles hier übergang macht von der
baureihe die beere kann ich so
beschreiben dass hier nur zeit punkte
sind ein punkt ist früher oder später
ich kann ja noch weiter gehen es gibt
nur zeitpunkt früher oder später
das ist jetzt dieses in diesem zitat
davor könnte man sagen ja hier klingt
auch schon ein bisschen die a 3 an aber
hier jedenfalls diesem zitat wie mir
scheint bringt er jetzt diese arbeit
spiel weil jetzt geht's um etwas was
noch nicht ist und was nicht mehr ist
hier geht die vergangenheit und zukunft
jetzt sagt er das jetzt ist ganz
interessant dass nun also hier dieses
wort hier das finde ich ganz interessant
also die griechische sprache erlaubt ist
wie die deutsche zeit wörter zu
substituieren also die griechen in dem
er altgriechischen kann man einen
artikel vor ein zeit fortsetzen
das jetzt das gestern das geht im
deutschen auch im lateinischen geht es
zum beispiel nicht das lateinische hat
gar keine artikel also demonstrative hat
es nach dieser diese dieses aber diese
normale substantive auch von infiniti
wie zum beispiel das essen also das
essen das das mittag gerichts und so das
kann die griechische sprache eben auch
sehr guter punkt der sie sprechen
wichtigen punkt an und das ist die
relativität der sprache und das an gibt
es auch schon in anderen hinsichten da
gab es eine große experimente in den
50er 60er inwiefern unsere onkologie
unsere welt vorstellung von unserer
sprache abhänge ob unsere begriffe die
wir über die welt legen es erlauben
manche bereiche schärfer zu sehen zum
beispiel bei manchen völkern die in
gegenden leben wo es mehr schnee gibt
dass die völker begriffe haben für ganz
kleine differenzen im schnee die uns mit
europa oder vielleicht noch wärmeren
gegenden die da gar nicht existieren
also dieses dieses begriffliche netz
sondern kann man sich dadurch erfahren
geht gibt es sprachen die über die zeit
so sprechen könnte das vielleicht oder
sprechen dass es gar keine zukunft gibt
gar keine vergangenheit es gibt
tendenziell sprachen wo das erhalte
sprachen wo die immo die derzeit nicht
so sind wie jetzt in der deutschen und
englischen sprache das gibt es also man
muss ehrlich gesagt auch hier immer
reflektieren die sprachliche relativität
in jeder rede von zeit
das müssen wir auch berücksichtigen wir
haben hier ein eurozentrismus also
durchaus eine konzentration auf
mitteleuropäische sprachen und wir
müssen natürlich versuchen diesen sprach
relativismus hinter uns zu lassen wir
müssen versuchen eine logische
bestimmung und begriffliche bestimmung
der zeit zu entwickeln oder zu
reflektieren die nicht abhängig ist von
unserer fakt von unsere tatsächlichen
sprache wie wir über die zeit reden das
ist völlig richtigen ist auch ein sehr
wichtiger hinweis dass wir das auch
immer
berücksichtigt man genau also dass es
diese vor allem nach der relativität
jetzt sagte aber hier die zeit besteht
nicht aus jetzt also dann ist jetzt die
gegenthese zu den vorherigen zitat da
war die vermutung da vermutet er ja es
könnte ja sein dass die zeit aus lauter
jetzt punkten versteht
und wenn das so wäre dann wäre die zeit
nicht existent war jeder jetzt punkt ja
nicht existiert weil er ja nicht
ausgedient sein kann
und jetzt sagt er aber hier das jetzt
ist nicht teil dieser zeit erst mal
weiter jetzt kommt ein sehr schwieriges
zitat das ist jetzt ein bisschen
schwieriger ich lese es auch nochmal vor
weiter sagte was das jetzt an geht
welches augenscheinlich vergangenes und
zukünftiges trend so ist nicht leicht zu
sehen bis die ganze zeit hindurch immer
ein und dasselbe bleibt oder ob es immer
wieder ein anderes wird es gibt
verschiedene möglichkeiten wenn es
einerseits wieder und wieder ein anderes
wird kein teil aber dessen was in der
zeit immer wieder ein anderes ding ist
gleichzeitig mit anderen sein kann
wer nicht der eine umfasst der andere
umfasst wird sowie ein kleinerer
zeitabschnitt von einem größeren
eingeschlossen wird und wenn was jetzt
nicht ist früher aber war notwendig
irgendwann einmal zu grunde gegangen
sein muss dann können auch die jetzt
nicht gleichzeitig im verhältnis
zueinander sein es muss jeder frühere
untergegangen sein genau während der
alten dauer kann es nicht zugrunde
gegangen seien weil es da doch gerade
war aber zur zeit eines anderen jetzt
kann das frühere jetzt auch nicht
untergegangen sein soll
dabei hat es nun möglich vorausgesetzt
sein dass die jetzt miteinander
zusammenhängen während sowie dass er
auch im verhältnis von punkt zu punkt
gilt
wenn es nun also in dem der reihe nach
sich anschließend nicht zugrunde
gegangen ist sondern hier ist in einem
weiteren dann wäre es ja noch in den
dazwischen liegenden jetzt die doch
unendlich viele sind vorhanden und so
gleichzeitig mit ihnen das kann nicht
sein
was ist jetzt hier so das argument haben
sie da eine idee was er sagt jetzt über
das jetzt wird das nun schreibt auch
noch mal hin also griechischen kp kommt
so eine möglichkeit drauf und das ist
dass nun neben deutschen das nun
wir sagen nun genau dieselbe wurzel wie
im kritischen griechisch und deutsch
sind verwandte in einer tiefen wurzeln
auch das englische ist mit dem
griechischen verwaltung das französische
auch also alle die meisten europäischen
sprachen sind mit dem griechischen
verwaltung man kann es bei einigen wird
dann wie zum beispiel sollen ganz
wichtiges es würde wie nun gibt es noch
sehr schön sehen
kleiner exkurs haben sie hier eine idee
was dieses argument ist anbelangt haben
sie da wir müssen es nicht in jedem
detail jetzt rekonstruieren das ist sehr
schwierig aber haben sie so einen
gedanken den man hier vielleicht sich
noch notieren sollte
[Musik]
ein
ja
heiligabend ist eine andere qualität
haben
genau
also darf es nicht sein sonst wäre ja
die zeit irgendwie auch nicht existent
an
haben sie noch einen punkt er sagt jetzt
mal dass jetzt das würde in der ersten
zeile wurde augenscheinlich vergangenes
und zukünftiges trennen und jetzt stelle
sich die frage ob es die ganze zeit
immer ein und das hebel bleibt oder ob
es immer wieder ein anderes wird die
frage ist was ist das jetzt eigentlich
was würden sie sagen bleibt das jetzt
dasselbe oder wird es ein anderes
das geht so ein bisschen in diese
richtung nicht genau dasselbe wir sind
diebe richtung der frage ob diese six ob
diese six in der zeit ruht also konstant
ist und die zeit durchfließt oder ob
diese six in der zeit sich bewegt so ein
bisschen diese richtung eins mitzugeben
wir sehen sie es bleibt das jetzt selber
oder werdet ein anderes das wird es sein
das bisschen schwierig also wenn man
sich mal die frage jetzt auch nicht zu
sehr vertieft aber wenn sie sich jetzt
mal schauen sondern jetzt
was spricht denn dafür dass ein jetzt
dasselbe bleibt derzeit spricht dafür
aber den aktionen mit einigen extras
dann wird natürlich und auch die zeit
und da
jetzt so verändert dass das heißt in
jeder runde ein
also man könnte sagen die also in eine
reihe also der bäckerei wären vielleicht
die jetzt gleich gleich net oder gleich
gleicher oder gleich geht es geht das
gleiche also hier wäre es wäre die frage
nicht so relevant während die frage hier
in der arena antritt weil da ist dass
das jetzt und es wird auch irgendwann
jetzt gewesen sein und dann kommt ein
anderer zeitpunkt der das jetzt ist also
wie so ein austausch der das jetzt wird
ständig ausgetauscht ist wie so ein
nachfolgemodell immer das aktuellste
modell ist jetzt ist dieses gerät schon
wieder zwei jahre alt jetzt kommt der
nachfolger das nachfolgemodell dann
stellt die frage ist es von derselben
hat dieses jetzt es ist irgendwie
insofern verschieden als das vormalige
jetzt eben vor malik war und so ein
altes jetzt ist sozusagen
aber es ist insofern gleich all das eben
auch mal jetzt war also ist von
derselben art man müsste vielleicht so
ein index hinzufügen dass jetzt eins das
jetzt zwei das jetzt drei und alle
vergangenen jetzt nummerieren und damit
sie sagen es ist von derselben art
vielleicht wenn es überhaupt so eine art
gehört aber es ist muss noch einen index
bekommen und es damit unterscheiden
jetzt
genau also sie haben völlig richtig
gesagt wenn wir der substanz ii wird
hier in diesem zitat das jetzt dass es
geht im griechischen da sagen wir dort
nun wahrscheinlich also jedoch so ein
tor davor das heißt
das ist das wird häufig wie im deutschen
als neutrum gefasst da es jetzt dass
heute das wort
das ist toll ist das griechische und
kann man sich fragen ja ist es nicht
meine ich falsch problematisch von dem
jetzt so zu reden als wäre es ein
gegenstand oder so und ein punkt also
dass problematisiert er jedenfalls haben
sie sonst noch eine anmerkung hierzu zu
diesem zitat sagt noch mal am ende
wenn es nun als ein dem der rhein nach
sich anschließend nicht zugrunde
gegangen ist das jetzt sollen erst in
einem weiteren dann wäre es ja noch in
den dazwischen liegenden jetzt jedoch
unendlich viele sind vorhanden und so
gleichzeitig mit ihnen also nimmt an
dass es unendlich dazwischen die jetzt
gibt und wenn er was für seine theorie
spricht er sagt es gibt unendlich viele
jetzt hat er dann eine diskrete oder
eine kontinuierliche theorie der zeit
sagt mit unendlich viel
kontinuierliche dann ist es geht es
sehen die richtung dieses zahlen straßen
wo man auch unendlich viele zahlen
punkte im zahlen strahl festmachen
können die man durch rationale
irrationale zahl und so weiter
ausdrücken kann durchbrüche und sofort
nach
ich denke wir gehen mal weiter auch wenn
man dieses zitat ist natürlich nicht
alle seine tiefe jetzt hier behandeln
können aber ich lese noch weiter aber
andererseits ist es auch nicht möglich
dass es die zeit hindurch immer das
jetzt dasselbe bleiben kein teil bares
begrenzt das ding hat nur eine grenze
einerlei ob es in eine richtung in
fortlaufenden zusammenhang steht oder
mehrere das jetzt ist aber eine solche
grenze und man kann ein begrenztes zeit
stück heraus greifen um mit man behalte
schon zwei jetzt eins am anfang eines am
schluss hätte aha
sehr klar also wenn es ein jetzt gibt
wenn es denn jetzt ein jetzt gibt dann
kann ich das ausgreifen sowie dieser
hinsicht wenn das 1 2 und nicht mehr
weiter analysiert werden
da habe ich hier eine grenze ich habe
hier begrenzt und soll klingst zukünftig
von vorne zu sagen und seine grenze zwei
grenzen namen
also könnte man sich jedenfalls
vorstellen wir lesen wir weiter über die
ihr zukommenden eigenschaften seien nun
so viele schwierigkeiten herausgestellt
was aber die zeiten wirklich ist was ihr
wesen ist das bleibt das ist jetzt die
physis hat die natur das bleibt
gleichermaßen unklar
einerseits aus den überlieferten
ansichten andererseits aus dem was wir
gerade im vorigen durchgegangen sind die
einen sagen nehme ich sie sei die
bewegung des als das ist das was sie vor
insekten so ein bisschen die anderen
setzen sie gleich mit der weltkugel
selbst davon dem umlauf braucht auch ein
teilabschnitt eine bestimmte zeit und er
ist noch nicht umlauf was man heraus
gegriffen hat ist ein teil des umlaufs
aber nicht umlauf was macht er jetzt was
ist jetzt seine strategie
also wie kann man jetzt versuchen die
natur die füße derzeit zu bestimmen ja
genau es gibt so ein vergleichs punkt
man versucht zeit mit bewegung von
irgendwelchen größen zu erklären
das ist jetzt eine möglichkeit das kann
man sich natürlich fragen gut ist es der
umlauf der die zeit ist das wirkt uns
wird davon so ein bisschen seltsam sagt
die zeit ist die bewegung des alls zeit
bewegung sind auch verschiedene dinge
wir können doch jetzt ist eigentlich
durch das andere erklären
und wie kann in die zeit die weltkugel
sein seltsamer lesen weiter da aber die
zeit in besonderem maße eine art
bewegung zu sein scheint und wandel so
wäre dies zu prüfen die verändernde
bewegung eines jeder gegenstandes wind
statt an dem sich verändernden allein
oder dort wo das abgelaufene veränderung
befindliche selbst gerade ist die zeit
dagegen ist die gleiche weise sowohl
über als auch bei allen dingen werden
sie aus diesem zitat schlauer leuchtet
ihm das mehr ein
was ist jetzt der unterschied zwischen
der zeit und der bewegung
wieso ist die zeit wir im ersten der
ersten zeile sagt eine in einem
besonderen maß eine bewegung
durchaus in diese richtung geht es wir
kommen ja jetzt noch bei newton drauf
jetzt in ein paar minuten aber überlegen
sie mal was er jetzt sagt ihrem letzten
zitat die zeit dagegen im letzten satz
teil satz die zeit dagegen ist in
gleicher weise wohl überall als auch bei
allen dingen also nicht mit pia
genau das kann ja auch versuchen ja gut
ist kann man sich fragen kann etwas
überhaupt ruhen
oder ist es nicht auch wenn es als holt
erscheint immer in bewegung
die moderne physik würde natürlich sagen
es gibt nicht diese absolute ruhe
es gibt eine absolute nullpunkt der
temperatur das gibt es nicht
ich weiß nicht minus 270 grad zu hass
minus 273 grad glaube ich der absolute
nullpunkt um diesen dreh ist es glaube
ich glaube zwei und da ist es wohl so
ich kann mich jetzt auch nicht so gut
aus das ist wohl so dass da auch
innerhalb der der atome keine bewegung
mehr stattfinden soll man überhaupt von
bewegung sprechen kann ist also ganz
interessante aggregatzustand dann aber
man könnte natürlich sagen ja gut
irgendwie ist immer warten aber ich
glaub es so im einzelnen denkt jetzt
aristotle ist nichts mehr sagt einfach
gut das ist da kann jetzt etwas gerade
ruhen sich nicht drehen aber dennoch
unterlegt ist derzeit deswegen ist zeit
und bewegung nicht auf derselben ebene
angesiedelt sondern die zeit die zeit
kann man sagen die ist der rahmen und
ich glaube in so eine richtung geht es
die zeit ist nichts was einem gegenstand
zukommt wie so eine eigenschaft also der
ball bewegt sich das ist ja mehr oder
weniger so eine eigenschaft des balls
der ball bewegt sich die zeit ist
letztendlich die form innerhalb dessen
bewegendes ist so könnte man mal jetzt
erst mal versuchen zu argumentieren
sie ist irgendwie generell oder sie
betrifft alle alles unterliegt derzeit
und nicht nur wenn es sich bewegt und
das wäre würde dafür sprechen dass eben
zeit jetzt nichts ist was jetzt im
gegenstand wie seine eigenschaft zukunft
die bewegung sind dass es ein genereller
rahmen ist innerhalb dessen der
gegenstand sich bewegen kann oder eben
auch nicht bewegen kann
das wäre eine möglichkeit also dann man
muss von zeit irgendwie anders sprechen
kann tim anerkannt macht das dann sehr
sehr differenziert kannte wird sagen ich
greife wieder ein bisschen voraus kann
wird sagen die zeit ist kein gegenstand
die zeit ist eine anschauungs form eine
reine anschauungs form ohne die zeit
können wir überhaupt gar keine
erkenntnisse haben überhaupt keine
wahrnehmung haben das setzt voraus dass
die zeit immer schon da ist die zeit ist
die bedingung der möglichkeit von
erkenntnis von erfahrung sie ist aber
selbst kein gegenstand erfahren sie
ermöglicht erst die erfahrung ist also
sondern eine höhere stufe eine höhere
stufe kategorien so ein bisschen diese
richtung könnte man jetzt dieses zitat
hier wie ist weil ich lese weiter weiter
veränderungen kann schneller und
langsamer ablaufen zeit kann das nicht
langsam und schnell werden ja gerade mit
hilfe der zeit bestimmt schnell dass im
geringer zeit weit voran schreitende
langsam dass in langer zeit wenig
fortschreitende die zeit dagegen ist
nicht durch zeit bestimmt wieder nach
der seite ihres wie viel noch dass der
iris wie geartet dass sie also nicht mit
bewegung gleichzusetzen ist
hier ist offenkundig dabei soll für uns
im augenblick ein unterschied besteht
zwischen den aus zu bewegung oder wandel
leuchtet ihnen das zitat ein was es
jetzt hier noch einmal das argument
warum kann zeit nicht mit bewegung
gleichgesetzt werden
hier sagt das
die zeit ist als der fehler wäre zu
sagen da bewegt sich was schneller
dann geht die zeit auch schneller das
ist ein irrtum weil wir nur sagen können
dass etwas schneller ist wenn die zeit
als konstant angesehen wird als ein
objektiver bezugspunkt an dem er es
ersichtlich wird ob etwas schneller oder
langsamer ist also wenn wir nicht die
zahl wir müssen um überhaupt sagen zu
können dass etwas schneller oder weniger
schnell sich bewegt davon ausgehen und
damit setzen wir schon voraus dass die
zeit konstant bleiben weil nur durch
seinen fixen bezugspunkt die konstante
zeit wir veränderungen als schnelle oder
weniger schnell bemessen können also die
zeit wird zu den objektiven kriterium
ein maßstab und der maßstab muss
natürlich konstant bleiben wenn wir von
schneller oder langsamer sprechen wollen
als interessant die zeit kann nicht
schneller langsamer verlaufen und dann
wird er durch albert einstein sagen
stimmt nicht die zeit kann sehr wohl
schneller oder langsamer verlaufen hängt
natürlich und jetzt ist es interessante
also ganz interessanter bezug jetzt zu
aristoteles einstellte sagen die zeit ob
sie nun schneller oder langsamer
verläuft hängt mit der geschwindigkeit
zusammen also das was aristoteles jetzt
hier in seiner physik ihr also eine art
von relation fast also die zeit ist das
maß der bewegung
das wird bei einstein so verändert in
dieser allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
dass er sagt die zeit hängt von der
bewegung ab alles total ist sagt die
bewegung hängt von der zeit ab die
bewegungsgeschwindigkeit können wir nur
anhand der konstant gedachten absoluten
zeit das ist das was jetzt auch gleich
null sagen wird gemessen werden und
einen stift halten denn in den nähe
je mehr wir uns der nicht geschehen
ich kann neben das tor unterschiedlich
schnell verläuft die zeit also hier ist
jetzt plötzlich die bewegung sprich die
lichtgeschwindigkeit dasjenige was auf
in richtung nicht geschwindigkeit geht
das maß das entscheidende
gerade die lichtgeschwindigkeit wird bei
einsteigern die möglichkeit bewegung
wird bei einstein fixiert fix gedacht
war ungefähr 300 tausend kilometer pro
sekunde 299,99 7
ein guter punkt es ist wohl gibt einen
dass es wäre dieser punkt wenn man diese
lichtgeschwindigkeit erreicht das wäre
dass es gibt diese grenzbereiche darauf
müssen wir eingehen also wenn wir uns
jetzt in einem also es so wenn wir uns
mehr lichtgeschwindigkeit wegen dann
altern wir weniger schnell
und dann stellt sich die frage was ist
jetzt wenn ihr die lichtgeschwindigkeit
erreichen und dann müsste prinzipiell
die zeit stehen bleiben
das wäre eine konsequenz jetzt mal ganz
allgemein gedacht wir würden wir müssen
das diskutieren ein will in zwei bis
drei sitzungen was passiert wenn man die
lichtgeschwindigkeit erreichen sie
können sie nicht erreichen aber wie
fühlte sich denn an ein lichtstrahl zu
sein dass wir wie ist es in einer
abwandlung dieses aufsatzes von thomas
niggl nicht wie es eine fledermaus das
sein sollen wie ist es ein lichtteilchen
zu sein ein photon was sich da mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegt und ein
photon hätte wenn es denn jetzt
empfinden könnte hätte eigentlich ein
ganz seltsames im zeitempfinden ganz
seltsame dann müssen wir auch versuchen
eine antwort darauf zu bekommen und kann
da auch meinen augen nur metaphorisch
davon sprechen aber ist jedenfalls so
dass da einstellen wie die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie spezielle sagte
spezielle ist es ja erst noch nicht die
allgemeine die spezielle also bei wo es
nicht um ein beschleunigungs systeme
geht da ist tatsächlich die zeit
abhängig von der bewegung oder in
lichtgeschwindigkeit dann interessanter
punkt mal hier jetzt wirklich mit
aristoteles und vielleicht noch ein
weiteres zitat aber andererseits ohne
veränderung ist sie auch nicht muss
nicht heißen wenn wir selbst in unserem
denken keine veränderungen vollziehen
oder nicht merken dass wir einen
vollzogen haben
dann scheint uns keine zeit vergangen zu
sein sowie die mythen erzählt werden von
denen
von denen die auf sardinien bei den
herren schlafen ihm fehlt auch die zeit
wenn sie wieder aufgewacht sind sie
verknüpfen nämlich mit dem früheren
jetzt das spätere und mache ein einziges
daraus vorbeisehen folge ihre empfindung
losigkeit die zeit dazwischen weglassen
das war die anhörung von kommilitonen da
ist man im schlaf doch auch so den
eindruck hat dass die zeit vielleicht
schneller vergangen ist ich meine mit
zimt wird sie eingeschlafen was ist
schon morgen schon 12 uhr
ich meine so schnell an die universität
mainz im jahr geben
sonst habe ich verschlafen das geht so
schnell wie also wie es also zeit gar
nicht gäbe wenn nicht das jetzt immer
wieder ein verschiedenes wäre von einem
dasselbe sagt also es muss um zeit geben
zu können dass jetzt immer ein
verschiedenes werden und das ist glaube
ich noch so ein hinweis dass aristoteles
hier denkt ein bisschen wir also die
verschiedenheit der zeit jetzt deutet in
meinen augen darauf hin dass eine an und
nicht nur eine
wer es um diese absoluten verhältnisse
geht kann man auch diskutieren
also muss muss eine verschiedenheit
geben
genau so erscheint hier das
zwischenstück nicht als zeit mussten da
die verschiedenheit der jetzt verborgen
bleiben wenn also der eindruck es
vergeht keine zeit sich uns dann ergibt
wenn wir keine veränderung bestimmend
erfassen können sondern das bewusstsein
in einem einzigen umgefahren jetzt
bleiben scheint und andererseits wir
veränderungen wahrnehmen und abgrenzen
bestimmen und dann sagen es sei zeit
vergangen ist offenkundig dass ohne
bewegung ohne veränderung zeit nicht ist
aha jetzt wieder ein bisschen wie ein
stein
das somit zeit nicht gleich bewegung
andererseits aber auch nicht ohne
bewegung ist leuchtet ein
ja wie sehen sie jetzt dieses argument
ihren leuchtend das 1
das zeigt auch ohne bewegung nicht
zahlen kann
heute dient es mit dem schlaf ein dass
die zeit im schlaf schneller vergeht es
ihm wirklich schneller im schlaf
fehlt den diesen herren die auf
sardinien schlafen die zeit
gedacht ist
ich hätte jetzt gesagt andersrum aber
wie meint sie ist jetzt also subjektiv
meinen sie nicht auch so meinen sie
okay aber hätten die hätten doch jetzt
den eindruck so lese ich hier hätten
doch jetzt den eindruck hoppla jetzt ist
schon wieder morgen und das was
dazwischen ist es so ich möchte mir ein
ich glaube ich auch dass kann man das so
sehen
genauer die würden dann sagen ging jetzt
aber schnell so also aus der perspektive
der herren ging das jetzt aber ganz
schnell
und was kann man jetzt darauf antworten
das könnte man jetzt das sagen
könnte jetzt sagen ja aber schaut mal
hier auf die zeit
wir könnten die kamera daneben stellen
und zwar hier schaut euch euren schlaf
an ihr habt schlafen schaut euch das
video an
er hat sieben stunden geschlafen alles
dokumentiert worden wir haben eine
kamera hingestellt so hier kannst
nachschauen du hast ganze zeit
geschlagen die zeit ist gelaufen du hast
du vergessen
das könnte man jetzt sagen dass halt nur
subjektives empfinden gibt sie aber noch
mehr argumente dass die zeit von der
bewegung abhängig ist das erste finde
ich nicht überzeugend mit diesen mit
diesem das ist rein subjektiv da ist
natürlich die zeit genau so schnell
vergangen da können die kamera daneben
stellen zeichnens auf und kann daher der
heraus kann dann der held kann dann das
nachprüfen wenn er wieder aufgewacht ist
haben sie noch zusätzlich ein argument
was man anführen könnte für aristoteles
dass die zeit von der bewegung abhängig
ist
also wir müssen hier wenn wir von
subjektive derzeit sprechen zwei
bedeutung streng auseinanderhalten denke
ich auch implizieren einmal die
subjektive zeit der a3 dass wir also
eine gegenwart eine vergangenheit eine
zukunft
sowas haben wir nur bei subjektivität
dass etwas noch nicht ist das ist eine
subjektivität von zeit nach der die zeit
total gleichförmig verlaufen kann
naja das ist nur der modus in der die
zeit wahrgenommen in der auch der modus
in der in dem die zeiten sich gestaltet
oder präsentiert ist die
präsentationsweise derzeit aber das
impliziert noch nicht dass die zeit
unterschiedlich schnell verläuft dann
gibt's noch eine zweite form von
subjektivität und vielleicht ihr
relativität sehen das zeitempfinden das
muss aber jetzt
es kann durchaus sein dass wir bei der
identischen zeitspanne eben
unterschiedliche zeiten finden haben
einmal vergeht schneller wir schätzen
die zeit falsch ein wir haben den
eindruck
aber das heißt nicht dass die zeit
schneller verläuft das leben ist eben
nicht wie sie richtig sagen
ja
genaueres ist da muss man ein bisschen
kritisch sehe ich bin auch nicht sicher
ob es wirklich so meint aber er sagt
jedenfalls ohne veränderung ist sie auch
nicht und da bringt er jetzt hier
es ist dann alle macht jetzt hier den
eindruck hier oben dabei ist wirkt es
auf mich so als ob er die zeit system
ist also die zeit abhängig macht vom
erkennen des objekt- und das scheint mir
problematisch zu sein
lesen wir vielleicht noch mal ein zitat
wir müssen also da wir ja danach fragen
was die zeit ist von dem punkt anfangen
dass wir die frage aufnehmen was an dem
bewegungs verlauf sie denn ist wir neben
bewegung und zeit jahr zugleich war ja
auch wenn dunkelheit herrscht und wir
über unseren körper nichts erfahren
wenn jedoch in unserem bewusstsein
irgendeinen vorgang abläuft dann scheint
alsbald auch zugleich ein stück zeit
vergangen zu sein in dessen auch
umgekehrt wenn eine zeit vergangen zu
sein scheint scheint gleichzeitig auch
eine bestimmte bewegung vor sich
gegangen zu sein also entweder ist die
zeitgleich bewegung oder sie ist etwas
an dem bewegungs verlauf da sind aber
gleich bewegung eben nicht wahr
so muss etwas an dem bewegungs verlauf
sagte was ist sie jetzt andere wege
da nun ein bewegtes sich von etwas fort
so etwas hin muss heißen wird und da
jede ausbildungs größe zusammenhängt ist
sofort ihren die bewegung der größe
wegen der tatsache dass größe immer
zusammenhängt ist ist auch bewegungs
verlauf etwas zusammenhängendes in
folgte bewegung aber auch die zeit wie
lange die bewegung verlief genauso viel
zeit ist anscheinend jeweils darüber
vergangen die bestimmungen davor und
danach gelten also ursprünglichen
ortsbereich das sind es als unterschiede
anordnung dem es nun aber auch beim
raumgrößen das davor und danach gibt so
muss notwendigerweise auch in den
bewegungs verlauf das davor danach
begegnen entsprechend den verhältnissen
dort aber dann gibt es auch in der 2
das davor und danach aufgrund dessen das
hier ja der eine bereich dem anderen
unter ihnen nachfolgen es ist aber dass
davor und danach bei der bewegung nichts
anderes als was bewegung geben ist
allerdings den begrifflichen seien nach
ist es unterschieden davon und nicht
gleich bewegung aber auch die zeit
erfassen wir indem wir bewegungsabläufe
abgrenzen und tut dies tun wir mittels
des davor und danach
und wir sagen dann die zeit das zeit
vergangen sei wenn wir von einem davor
und einem danach bei der bewegung
wahrnehmen gewinnen
die absetzung vollziehen wir dadurch
dass er sie die abschnitte immer wieder
als sie andere annehmen und mitten
zwischen den ein weiteres von ihnen
verschiedenes ansetzen wenn wir nämlich
die enden als von der mitte verschieden
begreifen und das bewusstsein
zwei letzte anspricht dass alle davor
dass andere nach dann sprechen wir da
von dieser zeit was nämlich begrenzt ist
durch ein jetzt das ist offenbar zeit
und das soll zugrunde gelegt sein langes
zitat sehr viele informationen wider
haben sie noch einen gedanken zu diesem
zitat zu unseren leitfragen wie
verhalten sich zeit und bewegung und
jetzt noch die interessante frage wie
verhalten sich zeit bewegung und raum
zueinander war jetzt bringt spricht der
hiervon raumgrößen hier
wie verstehen sie das
also was ist sondern sie analogie
zwischen raum und zeit
wovon spricht was ist sondern das
verbindende die verbindende
betrachtungsweise von raum und von zeit
bzw von bewegungs verlauf im raum
haben sie eine idee von was spricht er
er spricht von genau von dem davor und
danach
wie kann man das verstehen
davor nach wie kann man das so im raum
hier genau ist natürlich immer relativ
also ich bin jetzt irgendwie vor diesem
kasten und ich bin froh ihnen so eine
relation können wir hier stimmen ja okay
gut dass wir natürlich wieder zeitlich
dann gedacht aber es ist ganz eng
verflochten sie wollen sich auch noch
mit
okay das meint sie auch genau mir also
man sagt also örtlicher wechsel kann
sich kann sich zeitlich relation ihren
lassen als es in einem gewissen analogie
lässt sich das fast
wenn wir also das jetzt als ein einziges
wahrnehmen und nicht entweder als davor
und danach beim bewegungsablauf oder als
die eine und selbe grenze zwischen einem
vorherigen und einem nach jährigen
ablauf dann scheint keinerlei zeit
vergangen zu sein weil er auch keine
bewegung ab liegen wenn dagegen einen
davor und danach wahrgenommen wird dann
nennen wir es zeit und eben das ist zeit
die messzahl von bewegung hinsichtlich
das davor und danach
das ist jetzt seine definition können
sie das noch einen anderen worten re
formulieren wie verstehen sie jetzt
diese diese zeitbestimmung
durch diese sie neigen würden sie so
zeit auch bestimmen
was wenn wir einen jetzt gestimmt
und das wollen wir denn jetzt gibt dann
richtig das impliziert dass schon auf
eine gewisse weise aber er sagt eben
also wenn im ersten sieg im ersten satz
sagte wenn wir also das jetzt als ein
einziges wahrnehmen und nicht entweder
als davor und danach dann scheinen
keinerlei zeit vergangen zeit vergangen
zu sein als wir müssen das jetzt immer
auch mit einem davor und danach in
verbindung bringen aber da also dieses
davor und danach das ist jetzt natürlich
wenn sie noch mal hier auf diese
schauen sie doch mal auf die augen die
auf die b 3 wenn ihr jetzt sagt davor
und danach
das problem ist von ihm also wir dürfen
das jetzt wohl nicht als ein einziges
wahrnehmen was so verstehe ich ihn jetzt
ist ganz schwierig zu interpretieren ist
das jetzt immer als das identische weil
wenn wir das jetzt immer als derselbe
wahrnehmen da haben wir ja nur dass
jetzt wird praktisch keine gegenwart
aufgespannt in jeder zeitpunkt das jetzt
ist auch der schon gewesen ist das jetzt
ist dann bekommen wir nicht diese
differenzierung der bär ein spiel zweier
c und d also dann wäre das so dass hier
letztendlich wird überall der film buch
starke stehen musste also dass ich dann
zb hier geben einem auch 1 1 d haben und
hier so verstehe ich sitze noch eingehen
und so ein bisschen und dann wird
schwierig so also diese letzte dürfen
irgendwie nicht das darf nicht immer nur
dieses jetzt sein sondern müssen von den
letzten sagen eben dass sie davor und
danach sind wir müssen die jetzt index
kali sieren könnte man sagen also ich
sag ihr die einst die 23 das ist glaube
ich so die lösung haben jetzt aber es
halten jetzt das mal waren jetzt es eben
in der eine messzahl bekommt die
messzahl ist letztendlich der index und
dann kann man sich das räume ich so
vorstellen dass hier eben dieselbe
bewegung abgelaufen ist
diese ab die die messzahl der bewegung
also es müssen dann eben dieses wir
müssen praktisch hier anfangen wäre die
0 sozusagen hätten hier eine bewegung
die zweite dritte und das müssen
dieselben bewegungs zahlen alles
irgendwie die die erde dreht sich um die
sonnen oder nach der damaligen zeit die
sonne dreht sich um die erde
ja eben einmal zweimal dreimal
und dann haben wir halt ja oder
irgendwas anderes was eben sehr konstant
natürlich muss man darf voraussetzen
dass natürlich die bewegung gleichförmig
verläuft wir brauchen müssen natürlich
so ein bisschen ein problem was ich
damit hat wir müssen davon ausgehen ein
bisschen zäh cool er erscheint müssen
davon ausgehen dass die bewegung ja
schon zeitlich konstant ist als er
möchte die zeit mit der bewegung
erklären mit dem mars bewegung aber die
bewegung muss doch eigentlich schon
zeitlich einheitlich sein
das ist ein bisschen ein problem was ich
damit das ist das nicht ein bisschen
zirkuläre dass er jetzt also zeit mit
zeit erklären möchte jedenfalls in
bewegung sind einheiten die zum mars
geben gut er will ja auch die zeit mit
der zeit erklären dass weder ja auch er
will ja die zeit portionieren er will ja
die zeit ordnen und dann kann er das
durchaus mit der zeit machen und er muss
eben eine ordnung derzeit finden die an
die bewegung gebunden so könnte man das
sagen
natürlich legt diesen denken zu grunde
dass offensichtlich solche mutationen
zwischen sterne oder planeten
himmelskörpern dass die fix sind das die
absolut fest sind das ist diese prämisse
die er hier nicht explizit macht aber
das ist natürlich dieses antike welt
bildet der kosten muss kosmos aber
kritisch
roskosmos ist der schmuck also nach
diesem antiken griechischen verständnis
hat alles seine ordnung zwar die
perfekte ordnung das ist wie eine schöne
kette oder ein sonstiger
schmuckgegenstände es ist eine sehr
schöne ordnung die ordnung ist schön die
ordnung ist auch gut dass mal eine
normative dimensionen kontrolle an
spielt ist also auch gut so dass es ist
das die einzige möglichkeit das ist so
ist das ist auch gut so
das ist so dieses denken okay also diese
letzte dürfen nicht dieselben sein und
ich glaube dass er jetzt hier meine der
redaktion wieder eher auf die bereiche
zu sprechen konnten also hier spielt die
die subjektivität keine rolle weil davor
und danach sind keine prädikate die
abhängig sind von einem subjekt der
betrachtung ist wir sind absolut
absolute haupt barre aussagen die auch
gelten einem anderen tag als einer
anderen zeit
dass also die 2 nach der einst war das
gilt eben immer das ist nicht abhängig
von meinem standpunkt ich sage ja nicht
dass die zwei die zukunft ist diese
aussage das c2 die zukunft ist nur dann
wahr wenn ich wo bin ja
genau richtig hätte ich hätte jetzt
genauer sind oder zum beispiel die 1
genau sie haben recht recht eigentlich
zwischen den 0 und d2 also muss im
grunde genommen
deutlich älter als die zwei sein
das ist richtig aber davon wird jetzt
keine außer kein gebrauch gemacht
wir sagen nicht was es zukünftig
vergangen ist sondern sagen es ist
früher oder später ist eine absolute
relation
genau genau ich meine stellen sie sich
doch mal vor das denken jetzt die
griechen die antiken griechen nicht die
haben den kosmos aber es könnte doch
sein dass gibt es auch den fall
natürlich ist keine erdbewegung um die
sonne genau identisch
also genau gleich lang bestimmt nicht
also auf die sekunde auf gar keinen fall
da kommen irgendwie immer irgendwie
gravitations und so dass die erde ist ja
auch nicht perfekt die die rote ganz
kompliziert natürlich ist das nicht nur
ein so wird halben jahr definiert klar
aber da gibt es scheint ja und dann gibt
es noch eine schaltsekunde und dann
wieder war es sehr man muss ständig
tricks anwenden das gleich ein wichtiger
punkt um die illusion aufrechtzuerhalten
dass die zeit durch natürliche umkreise
natürliche bewegungen angegeben werden
könnte das können wir nicht
aufrechterhalten weil die bewegung nicht
absolut identisch sind ist nicht perfekt
wir haben in der natur keine perfekten
einheiten bitten wir die zeit messen
können müssen dann die zeit anders
messen und jetzt gibt es ja diese es
gibt jetzt sekunde ist praktisch wird
dann über den weg angegeben den
irgendwie etwas zurückliegt oder so wenn
man kann das durchaus mit natürlichen
größen machen natürlich auch mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit und so weiter die
lichtgeschwindigkeit ist konstant über
sowas kann man das zum beispiel macht ne
aber ob man es mit seiner bewegung der
erde um die sonne oder der sonne um die
erde machen geht uns natürlich nicht
sondern um die erde um die sonne
ob man es damit machen kann weiß ich
nicht
extrem anschauen
diese
künstlichkeit und die sind eben nicht
wenn man
wir schließen lässt dass man die
ja gut ab und sie haben wie in wichtigen
punkt genannt weil das hatten wir jetzt
gerade wieder diese zeitumstellung in
die winterzeit
dann wird es wieder früher dunkel und
früher natürlich auch hell aber das ist
richtig also das ist glaube ich der
grund ist jetzt nicht dass man das macht
meines wissen um da wieder so eine
korrektur anzubringen um diesen
kreislauf hinzubekommen sind dessen
ökonomische erwägungen aber man geht
damit sehr willkürlich um mit dieser
zeit und man merkt sich das es dass man
man glaubt man könnte über die zeit
verfügen das auch so interessanter punkt
und glaubt man könne die zeit
beeinflussen
ja und das kann man eben nur sehr
begrenzt machen als ich wollte ihn jetzt
hier nur demonstrieren anhand der zitate
von aristoteles das stark mit bewegung
und mit messzahl versucht zu erklären da
aber die unausgesprochene prämisse
zugrunde liegt dass es in der natur
total identische arten von bewegung gibt
die natürlich genau so lange dauern
das ist impliziert und das müssen wir
heute nicht mehr annehmen
das ist heute nicht mehr so das ist
nicht auf die tausendstelsekunde genau
so natürliche bewegung auch zyklische
bewegung die sind nie genau seitlich
identisch damit können wir eigentlich
zeit mich richtig dastehen weil dann ist
einmal halt die bewegung ein bisschen
dauert ein bisschen länger und die ein
bisschen kürzer und haben wir schon
wieder nicht die richtige zeit damit mir
also er setzt voraus dass ist ein kosmos
gibt kosmos heißt ordnung perfekte
ordnung
also alles läuft nach so einem
masterplan sozusagen das ist sein metier
sind so jetzt möchte ich aber auch nicht
halt jetzt vielleicht noch ein zitat
hier also sagt er nicht gleich bewegung
vieles ist die zeit soll es soweit die
bewegung zahl an sich hat das ist das
hier die diese indexe die 123 diese
bewegung durch neue für als es die
portionierte die abgeschlossene bewegung
die einheitliche bewegen die
abgeschlossen das ist die zeit
natürlich liegt der zugrunde das ist
eine bewegung die genauso lange dauert
wie die andere bewegung also bewegung
die genau denselben rhythmus
letztendlich die periodisch
wiederkehrende könnte man das sagen
genau ein beleg dafür dass mehr und
weniger entscheidende mittels der zahl
mehr oder weniger bewegung mittels
derzeit eine art zahl ist also die zeit
würden sie dem zustimmen das mehr oder
weniger
das sagen hat
das ist egal wie lang ist da wo ich bin
ja oder punkt die frage ist hier was er
mit bewegung mein ich glaube mein tier
die gleiche bewegung als dieselbe
bewegung also wenn sie sich so ein
kreislauf vorstellen man gleich schnell
ist also nicht sondern ich weiß nicht so
eine uhr die geht der uhrzeiger der
wandert mehr bewegung meint nicht dass
es dass er schneller läuft sozusagen
sondern dass er häufiger die bewegung
vollzogen hat diese uhren und das wird
mit der zeit messen
ja jetzt setzt natürlich voraus dass die
bewegung wieder konstant ist es scheint
mir so diese diese prämisse zu sein also
dass das fazit ist eine art zahl ist
also die zeit als eine in mexikanische
bewegung könnte also ein bewegungsablauf
der abgeschlossen ist prämisse nach
genau identisch verläuft und der eine
zahl bekommt und damit können wir dann
die zeit messen mit bewegungseinheiten
perioden mit einer abgeschlossenen
abläufen von bewegungen die eben immer
wieder kennen und da ist glaube ich
bestimmt als hintergrund die also dass
der jahresablauf gezeiten ablauf so was
also jahres die wiederkehrenden
jahreszeiten die bewegung der erde um
die sonne damals der sonne um die erde
das ist glaube ich der hintergründen und
wir müssen das problematisieren wir
müssen sagen die bewegung ist nicht ist
nicht gleich sollte ist es kein maß die
ändert sich es gibt störungen es könnte
zum beispiel sein dass ein asteroid
jetzt mal hier
die riesen als theorie die sonne
zerstört ja was ist dann oder die sonne
jetzt endlich so irgendwie beeinflusst
dass der umlauf der erde um die sonne
länger dauert ist genauso ist es von der
art her vom typus her wäre es dann auch
eine bewegung der erde um die sonne
aber es würde länger dauern das so also
man muss voraussetzen dass es halt
gleichartig ist und das ist so eine
gewisse prämisse die nach ins spiel
kommt
so jetzt möchte ich aber ganz kurz noch
hier dass man in der zusammenfassung auf
diesen herren hier eingehen kurz und das
ist
newton der natürlich wesentlich jünger
ist derzeit machen wir jetzt eine riesen
zeitreise ein zeitsprung in die jüngere
zeit in die frühe neuzeit könnte man
sagen da gehört er hin also wirklich
revolutionen wurden er da gemacht und
isaac newton ist wie sie wissen wie auch
der titel seines werks schon sagt die
mathematischen prinzipien der natur
lehre des große verdienst von newton
besteht darin die natur quantifiziert zu
haben also mathematische modelle
operationen auf die natur übertragen zu
haben die natur mathematisierung zu
haben
das setzt voraus dass sich die natur nur
noch nach wirklichkeit bestimmt ich gebe
auch noch eins im java kausalität und da
wird es auch bald eine rolle spielen als
er betrachtet die natur nur nach
wirklichkeit strukturiert und nicht mehr
nach vorne ursächlichkeit nach stoff
ursächlichkeit und nach zweck
ursächlichkeit sowas wie technologie wie
zweck ursächlichkeit
das war's fragt wozu macht jetzt das
eine ding das andere ja weil das das
will oder die natur das will die spiele
für ihn keine rolle man könnte auch
sagen dass so ein positivismus er schaut
nur nach den fakten und schaut nach
ursache und willkommen und in sehr
quantitativen verhältnis also es geht um
relationen letztendlich der denn der
natur bewegungen der natur gegenstände
natur entwicklung und man kann es
natürlich so machen dass man dann
versucht bewegung der himmelskörper
mathematischen zu beschreiten oder dass
man zum beispiel versucht zu schauen
nach welcher form der der funktion also
in den funktionen fast und schaut
beschleunigt bewegungen welche funktion
passt am besten drauf ist eine
quadratische gleichungen und so weiter
das ist dieser große vorteil dass man
also sagt wir können naturgesetze oder
natur ja größen bestimmen auf eine
mathematische weil sie aus anderen
größen zum beispiel dass ich
beschleunigung und geschwindigkeit
auseinander gewinnen kann indem ich das
eine ableite und dann aufs andere kommen
dass also die beschleunigung die
ableitung der geschwindigkeit ist dann
bekomme ich eben ein halb davor
plötzlich
ursprünglich war es ganze zahlen die
ganze größe und wenn nichts ableiten
bekomme ich ein halb plötzlich wie kommt
es dass da plötzlich ein halb davor 05
wegen einem ableitungsrohr hält nist und
das ist so dieser klasse dass ich
bewegung und geschwindigkeit und
beschleunigung aus rein abstrakten
verhältnissen heraus gewinnen kann und
dass die natur letztendlich diesen
formeln dann auch folgt also ich kriege
so sagen die logik kriegt die logik der
natur die kann ich destillieren und wenn
ich die logik man habe dann kann ich
wieder logik weiter arbeiten und sie
weiter kombinieren und plötzlich merke
ich dann wenn ich die logik die ich mir
der entwickelt hat wieder mit der natur
vergleiche dass die natur mit der logik
übereinstimmt das heißt ich hab die
logik der natur
erfasst und rekonstruiert und das ist
dieser große ein diese geniale
errungenschaft also wirklich eine
eigenständige logik entwickelt zu haben
und die weite gedacht zu haben und dann
dass man sehen kann wenn man macht damit
voraussagen und die passen mit der natur
zusammen so hat es ja letztendlich dann
auch auf eine andere weise albert
einstein gemacht auch mit viel gedanken
experiment und auch oder in einer
gewissen weise apriori schon im
tierische da daten haben zu müssen an
einer gewissen weise und dann macht man
die erfahrung hoppla 100 jahre später
plötzlich zeigt sich dass einsteins
formel stimmt dass wir als naturereignis
beobachten können die wir mit diesen
vorhersagen gut erklären können
und jetzt kann man sich fragen verhält
sich also newtons zeitverständnis zudem
bei aristoteles in akkus teams und vor
allem was versteht minuten unter der
absoluten zeit können sich eigentlich
schon denken was damit gemeint ist es
eben diese absolut gleiche rahmen die
zeit ist überall gleich schnell verrät
gleichen zeitraum ort und bewegung als
allen bekannt erkläre ich nicht bemerken
nur dass man gewöhnlich diese größen
nicht anders als in bezug auf die sinne
auf fast und so gewisse vorurteile
entstehen zu deren aufhebung man sie
passend im absolute und relative ware
unscheinbare mathematische ungewöhnliche
unterscheiden die frage ist jetzt kann
in so einer mathematisch informierten
natur lehrer überhaupt zeit raum und ort
eine rolle spielen wenn es doch um die
berechnung von umlaufbahn geht von
gestirnen absolute ware und
mathematische zeit verfliest an sich und
vermögen ihrer natur gleichförmig und
ohne beziehung auf irgendeinen äußern
gegenständen sie wird also mit dem namen
dauer belegt das ist eigentlich das
wichtigste zutat vermuten
jetzt hat er hier natürlich wieder weiß
problematisches gemacht er hat hier eine
die tabuisierung vorgenommen hat gesagt
sie verschließt und ganz wichtig ist
ohne beziehung auf einen äußeren
gegenstand sie ist absolutes meint
dieses absolut ohne beziehung absolut
lateinisch meint losgelöst
ohne in einem verhältnis absolviert
kommt von lateinisch soll wäre die
solutions' solution ist die lösung und
abzulöschen und losgelöst ohne
beziehungen da ist diese absolute zeit
angesprochen und das wird natürlich
albert einstein ansage in seiner
speziellen wie ich mich jetzt
korrigieren muss speziellen
relativitätstheorie dass das eben nicht
so ist es gibt diese absolut zeit mich
sie ist abhängig von bewegung und das
ist was äußeres düsen äußere größe
außerhalb der zeit
und sie ist nicht absolut hängt ab von
der geschwindigkeit die begrenzt ist die
geschwindigkeit müssten newton nach
heutiger sicht korrekt zahlen die
geschwindigkeit ist absolut es gibt eine
absurde geschwindigkeit das ist die
lichtgeschwindigkeit zwar 99,97 noch was
tausend kilometer pro sekunde einzeltat
die relative scheinbare und gewöhnliche
zeit ist ein fühlbare sind äußerliches
entweder genaues oder ungleich ist
master dauert das man sich gewöhnlich
statt der waren zeit bedient die stunde
tag monat ja
das ist also die zeit portion und das
ist das was aristoteles offensichtlich
mit dieser zählbaren zeit meint das ist
eine konkrete zeitspanne die eigentlich
nur über die bewegung definiert wird
eine stunde ist eben der 24 detail eines
tages der tag ist eben der 30 33 ist
hans monath und der monat ist eben der
zwölfte teil eines jahres also
letztendlich ist eine stunde abhängig
vom jahr und das jahr ist letztendlich
definiert als eine rotation der erde um
die sonne und das ist letztendlich recht
willkürlich so verstehe ich das ist also
die relative zeit ist abhängig von einer
bestimmten weg um zu verstehen dass
unklar ist mir jetzt hier wieso
erfüllbare sind äußerliches und nun
gleich ist gleiches ungleich vielleicht
deswegen weil die bewegung eben nicht
ganz gleichförmig sind absolut gelten
das könnte man das nur problematisieren
dabei möchte ich es für heute belassen
sie sehen also hier newton ist gegenüber
aristoteles sehr kritisch eingestellt
muss man noch dazu sagen weil bei
aristoteles spielte die theologie die
zweck ursächlichkeit noch eine sehr
große rolle aristoteles kannte vier
arten von verursachung stoff ursache
form als ursache wird ursache und zweck
ursache und newtons kennt nur noch eine
ursache die wirkung sachen sieht man als
sehr kritisch eingestellt gegenüber
und hier ist also sehr wichtig der
begriff der absoluten zeit wir werden in
der nächsten sitzung da noch mal kurz
darauf zu sprechen kommt das ist jetzt
nicht weiter schwierig dann machte keine
großen anwendung von formeln und wollen
dann der nächsten sitzung eine debatte
zwischen zwischen newton und an anderen
lenker der hits klar kann engländer und
leibnitz betrachten was den status der
zeit anbelangt und die frage ist jetzt
dann die ist zeit eine form also wie
existiert zeit existiert seit in den
dingen an der bewegung oder ist eine
form innerhalb dessen
bewegung erst stattfinden kann dann bis
zur nächsten sitzung